hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my Gammage and series
so last time we didn't look at vertex
buffer layouts and we designed a class
that could handle all of that stuff kind
of for us and elegantly so that it
looked nice definitely make sure that
you check out that video because it's
it's really informative I think a lot of
people like to as well
and it's definitely necessary for kind
of what we're moving on with next which
is going to be talking about vertex
arrays and that's what we're going to do
in this video today so vertex arrays are
essentially in OpenGL they're kind of
defined as I mean they're a bit weird to
be honest if I'm being completely honest
with you I really think that should
exist I do have a video covering vertex
arrays in the OpenGL series check that
out again just like with the previous
video in this series I don't want to
just explain a lot of stuff that I've
already explained in the past so check
out that video if you want more details
but essentially vertex arrays are a kind
of state containing entity right so what
they better actually contain any real
data like your vertex buffer is what
contains your vertices your index buffer
is what contains the indices those two
pieces of kind of like those two buffers
are your actual buffers they're memory
buffers they have your actual data what
the vertex array actually contains is
just references essentially to a vertex
buffer and to an index buffer and also
to something called a layout which is of
course what we talked about in the last
episode so basically what happens is you
create about X ray and then you can bind
a vertex buffer to it and a vertex and
sorry an index buffer to it and those
two kind of things right leave inside
that vertex array now it's important to
note that when I say they live inside it
it doesn't mean that like literal
literal copies of them kind of live
inside it's not that kind of living as
that what I'm actually talking about is
the vertex array is associated with
those two kind of with the vertex buffer
and the index buffer but it's not
actually like it doesn't control its
lifetime right and you know if you like
modify the vertex buffer itself it's
gonna modify the same one
inside the vertex array because the
vertex array just has links like
pointers right they just have pointers
to an existing vertex buffer and to an
existing index buffer that are actually
contain their own that aren't own the
vertex buffer and in and the index
buffer they just kind of reference them
right and then the other thing that it
has is essentially all of the layout
kind of information of a vertex buffer
so just like in the last episode we
talked about how we have to use like you
know vertex attribute pointers and we
set up above a layout class and all of
that kind of stuff right that is taught
kind of per vertex buffer as I said but
what happens is that state is stored in
your array in your vertex array which
means that when you rebind a vertex
buffer you don't need to redefine its
layout unless it's changed right and
this works a little bit differently for
multiple vertex buffers because what you
can do is you can actually have a vertex
array and then have like several vertex
buffers containing different information
like you might have one for like
positions one foot normals one foot
bones one for whatever it is that you're
dealing with right and in that regard
they're still in the vertex right but
what you do is you actually behind the
vertex array bind the vertex buffer set
the layout for the bird for the vertex
buffer then you bind your next vertex
buffer set its layout with the vertex
array still kind of bound right so you
kind of just do it that way
Almond but that's not something that
we're really going to touch on today
because using multiple vertex buffers
isn't something that's very commonly
done anyway because it's usually better
to just interleave all of your data in a
single vertex buffer which is what we've
been doing but that's kind of the gist
of how it works
and with an index buffer as well a
vertex array does actually tie that in
which means basically that it also
references that so it's not just for
vertex buffers and and their
corresponding layouts
it's also the case for index buffers
right for element buffers one other
thing I want to mention is that there
are some new functions in OpenGL for 4.5
maybe not sure I'll probably make an
OpenGL series like episodes it'll be
about this anyway
but there are new functions to make this
tying together a little bit more clear
because it's completely just it's messy
right OpenGL API in general is
not that great it definitely is a lot
better with the introduction of these
new functions but basically it just
means that you can tie together like a
vertex buffer or a layout or an index
buffer or anything into a vertex array
without having to bind a bunch of state
you actually just specify the ID of the
array the ID of the vertex buffer it
just kind of ties them together that way
which it makes a lot more sense
something that we might explore in the
future but I don't really want to
restrict this stuff to I guess I've been
gel four point-five said it's big and
it's not really something that I've
explored myself yet but I will probably
make an open gel upset about that
because I think that's worth kind of
exploring anyway let's jump in and take
a look at how we can set up a vertex
alright class before we do that one more
thing that I want to say is that in
vertex and raised in general I'm not
something that really exists in like
DirectX or the kind of the choice that
we have to make here is how do we set
this up in an abstract away right and as
I said right now this engines focusing
on OpenGL probably for quite a while
right because I would much rather get
like you know a full game engine kind of
up and running using OpenGL first right
and then start filtering in the other
api's because this is gonna be this is
gonna take less time it's gonna just
work better and we're gonna have an
actual product to show a lot quicker
than if we kind of try and just do all
the api's at once so that's why for now
even though it kind of hurts me inside a
little bit I'm gonna ignore DirectX and
how DirectX deals with things I mean to
a point right if it's an easy change
then I'm obviously gonna make it but
something like this is not easy because
it requires changing kind of a lot of
the renderer API architecture because
since this is like obviously if we
mandate that you have to create vertex
arrays and then a vertex buffer for
example in your array and that's not
something DirectX has one needs that's
going to require some real protection to
take place usually a quick fix is just
basically having vertex array just do
nothing in DirectX right so you can you
can still create a vertex array in your
kind of API in your render API agnostic
API right which basically means that in
your in our kind of hazel render API
we can still create a better house
buffer I'm sorry about this all right
you know OpenGL it will create an actual
vertex right in DirectX it can literally
just do nothing so that's one thing that
you can do and probably what we're gonna
do right now because we need to get up
and gel to work anyway let's dive in and
take a look okay so the last time we had
this triangle we defined it by just kind
of creating this layout here right so we
have position in color over here but the
one thing that really kind of sucked for
us was that this kind of vertex array
stuff was not abstracted whatsoever
right and neither was this layout stuff
so that's kind of what we're gonna try
and do right now we're gonna create a
vertex all right
so over here in renderer I'm gonna make
a new item it's gonna be a vertex array
and then you know namespace hazal this
is gonna be kind of it's gonna kind of
follow the same I'm always tempted to
put it into before the reason I didn't
put it in to buffer the reason why I
wanted as a separate he had a header
file here and like a separate like it's
a separate file it's just because it's
gonna be a little bit different I'm just
a coffee bath thanks Pablo it's gonna be
a little bit different because I'm not
even sure if I want to keep it long term
or maybe we can hold something else so I
don't really want to kind of deal with
that I guess for now I don't even know
what I'm including probably don't need
much I guess falling twigs buffer
renderer delays so for now I'm kind of
just keeping it separated because I'm
not sure what its future is gonna be so
we have a vertex array will have a
destructor this is again the kind of
platform sorry the renderer API agnostic
like interface in terms of creation I
think just you can just create it like
that it doesn't really need any
parameters sad layouts not gonna be a
thing what we can do is actually add a
buffer to it so add I'm just thinking
the best way to do this will have will
have will have um add vertex buffer
so virtual void add vertex buffer and
then this will just take in a vertex
buffer okay so we we don't what we
actually want to take in is a ref I
might talk about this in the future for
now we're just gonna take in a shared
pointer the way that resources are gonna
work inside hazel is basically
everything every resource kind of
related thing like a vertex buffer and
index buffer a texture a shader all that
kind of stuff is going to be a reference
counted right so they're basically gonna
be shared pointers now if I was really
like pedantic and really specific about
performance and all of that I probably
want to create an intrusive reference
counting system but I don't like I don't
actually think shared pointer especially
if the actual reference count block is
inline in memory I don't actually think
that it's gonna perform worse so for now
we're just gonna deal with that
Ryan but what we're gonna just take in a
constant red pointer vertex buffer and
we'll just call this I guess vertex
buffer okay and in the future what we
might do is just kind of because the
implementation might change and we don't
want to change our code anywhere I
usually like changing like basically
changing the actual type name to be
something else but we will talk about
that in another episode so have add the
vertex buffer will have will have kind
of a taupe do they have had will have an
index buffer as well at index buffer
which will take in an index buffer will
actually probably have an empirical
constant you will probably have some
kind of like ownership actually taking
place will have bind and unbind now in
the previous classes we also have bind
and unbind it's not that necessary but
for vertex arrays you actually kind of
do want to unbind them potentially
unless you like I it's again as I said
it's good for testing and I can I can
kind of show you what I mean by that
maybe in another video get interested as
to why on earth I write unbind
everywhere I mean I don't write it in my
code I mean I'm well but why the API
supports it
but there might be something that we
talk about later - good memory as well
access to SharePoint - okay cool so
there we have vertex array let's grab
this file let's make a CPP file for it
vertex array dot CPP and of course I
made a typo that's not my fault I swear
the letter R didn't punch in twice will
include the PCH and vertex array dot H
namespace hazel and then we really just
have the create function of course I'll
copy and paste that and we will copy and
paste the implementation of this from
buffer dot CPP so typical scenario now I
have been using pointers up until now oh
ok so we could return a shared pointer
here and we could deal with the refs but
obviously you can also return a roll
pointer like this and then capture it
into either either a shared pointer or a
unique pointer so that's why for now
before we may be switched to more of a
ref system as I said because that's what
we're gonna it's kind of where we're
heading towards if you want to do that
yourself right now you absolutely can
but because that's where we're heading
towards I'm not gonna bother kind of
changing that I guess now so this will
return an OpenGL vertex array and that
looks pretty good to me I think so now
in platform platform OpenGL over here
I'm going to add OpenGL vertex array dot
H and OpenGL vertex array dot CPP this
will include the PC age not the hand at
the coordinates in space and
the urban gel that's right had a
filename space hazel okay
so include hazel oops
hazel brand raw vertex array and then my
typing right now is not that great what
happens when you try and do this kind of
stuff in the morning so let's go to our
vertex array I guess and pretty much
copy most of it I'll just copy the whole
class to be honest this is gonna be an
OpenGL vertex array which will be a
vertex array so what we're gonna do is
so I'll just pop that in let's see so
we'll change this to say override for
all of them and then we've still got our
binding I'm binding which is good okay
cool and then we don't need to create
obviously so in terms of stuff that
we're actually keeping so we do actually
want to have some kind of list I guess
so vector of shared pointer vertex
buffer okay
so week week actually contain references
through every vertex buffer that we
actually put in so just like be just
like OpenGL is doing internally we're
kind of mimicking or mirroring that on
the CPU here by just having a list of
all vertex buffers and index buffers
don't believe you can have more than one
index buffer to be honest I don't think
I've ever done that before so I might
change this to set index buffer I might
be wrong maybe it's possible somehow but
to be honest I've never seen it before
I've never done it before so for now
we'll just call this set index buffer
and we'll just have one so that behavior
that I kind of described to you guys on
how this works so you can see that we're
kind of recreating it in code now which
can't the goal of all of this so let's
see what we have here nothing which is
good I'm gonna use visual assist here to
just create all the method
implementations and here we have
everything so we obviously need to have
a constructor as
so let's just have a constructor and
[Music]
what's next so in the constructor we
want to obviously create everything if I
look at just buffer you can see that we
sorry vertex buffer
I'm sorry GL GL buffer you can see that
we simply just create everything come
here right I'm gonna do the same thing
with vertex arrays so over here in my
vertex alright I'm just gonna call GL
create vertex arrays and then I guess
I'll table type in one and then we
render our ID and what do we use for the
render ID because I always forget it's
just a unsigned int so as I said we
probably will end up like type deafening
that into something else that Canal is
just that now that I seem to have gotten
this wrong maybe so let's take a look at
this no that's right
maybe that's just not working because of
me not including glass or something like
that yep okay cool so we can create a
vertex array and that's pretty much it
for binding we just bind the vertex
array so she'll find vertex array right
and it's just the renderer ID barn bind
again we just find zero for advert X
buffer so what we need to do is actually
make sure the array is bound now things
I want ask the question of why I don't
just call bind here like this the reason
I don't do that is because I I don't
generally like to like mix OpenGL calls
were just my own calls obviously in some
situations it's necessary if you're
doing really complex stuff but if it's
just one line like this I would much
rather have it actually just be written
here and the reason for that is that a
lot like in the future we might add
stuff to bind right we might add stuff
to unbind or whatever feel like you know
tracking essentially or profiling
purposes I don't necessarily want this
to register itself as an actual bind as
if it's been called by the game or by
the renderer because this is kind of API
internal things right so because there's
API internal things you know this is
like totally fine to call and I
definitely don't want these
to start branching out into a bunch of
other functions needlessly if it's
necessary for sure right like if I had a
function called add vertex and index
buffer right and it just did both I'd
definitely call this in this I wouldn't
write I wouldn't copy and paste the
whole OpenGL code there but in this
situation it's just a simple bind no
need to just divert you know divert it
into a different function and just
complicate things by doing that
essentially okay so then once we bound
our vertex array what we actually want
to do is bind our vertex buffer so in
this case of course I will call that as
well for bind because you know this is
dealing with an actual API object here
it's not dealing with its own kind of
class I'm definitely not gonna do
anything like GL bind if everything's
bluff and then vertes buffer get
renderer ID or something disgusting like
that
so we're doesn't gonna bind it now what
I need to do once I've found it if we go
back to application is I need to
basically do all of this stuff so pretty
easy to do I can just copy this code and
paste it into here right because that's
kind of the idea and vertex buffers
layouts gonna get changed here now this
shader type again at the moment we're
gonna grab it and we're gonna eventually
might live inside some kind of OpenGL
like shader class but for now we're just
gonna put it into the top of our vertex
array over here okay I'll make sure
that's time to cross all right and let's
see it back that's really all that we
have to do obviously I also want to
actually add the vertex buffer to our
list of vertex buffers so i'll type in m
vertex buffers dot pushback vertex
buffer okay and now we'll just add it to
our list of vertex buffers but that's it
right if we suddenly decide that like
that that's fine we want to add another
like vertex buffer or something to this
with a different layout that's totally
fine and it will work okay just because
we're doing it kind of this way okay
cool
and then at the end of this it's not
really necessary to unbind anything I'm
just thinking others now I don't think
that we need to nothing's gonna go wrong
if you bind another vertex array before
I'm binding this
I don't think I think it's the actual
binding that ties it together since this
is why the API is terrible and that's
why they changed it but um so I think it
should be safe I don't think suddenly
it's gonna belong to a different vertex
array or anything like that
um here again we're gonna copy this this
is really easy it's basically just
copying this right so we'll copy
yep that and then instead of vertex
buffer bind we're doing index buffer
bind right and then that's actually it
right that's that's it
we don't need to do anything else like
obviously we'll add it to our wall so
we'll set it you know index laughs I
don't know why it's called an index
buffers because it used to be a vector
we'll change that to index buffer but
that's it right this alone binding it
and then just binding binding the vertex
array then binding an index buffer
associates it to the vertex array I know
it's crazy I hate it so there's pretty
much everyone else that's why they kind
of changed it or try to make it they
didn't change it but they made
additional API so that you could write
that code instead that would be a more
readable which we'll explore as I said
in the future but that's how to OpenGL
traditionally works so there your fun
times I think that should be it
so now let's take a look at what we can
do inside our actual application class
so this this is now gone right we'll
keep this code because we're setting
that up this should be gone right and I
think we also have a bind vertex array
up in the application sorry in the
update or render whatever functions
called in the run loop in the run
function so what we'll do is go over
here we'll create a and as I said we're
gonna kind of get used to creating
shared pointers but until we have that
properly set up I kind of want to just
stick with what we have here this will
create a vertex array I'll put it up
here it's kind of a parent of these two
so we have a vertex array which is a
unique point it just like everything
else will include that
and then we'll do that accelerator
resets and that's us simply creating it
I can write the work create so we've
created it that's done right now what we
need to do is again doesn't really
matter we can create anything we want we
can bind anything anything we want now
this is dangerous and this is what I
some somewhat like I'm binding because
if you leave this bound and you bind it
something else which happens obviously
when we create the vertex buffer there
suddenly associated together that's a
little bit dangerous okay because you
know as I said the thing that has her
she has them together is just binding
another vertex buffer while a vertex
right bound that's kind of dangerous I
don't like that because as we said you
know it's nice to just have you know we
have a specific function here that we
want to call which is basically just
saying that we want to add a vertex
buffer to a vertex array right and it's
currently okay we will have to change
everything to check pointers otherwise
it's gonna work very cleanly um this
could be a good time to do that so this
just becomes shared point though nothing
really changes by the way this just
becomes shed pointer and that's the only
change really so over there saying yeah
so if we do that if we add the vertex
buffer right at this point it binds the
vertex array and the vertex buffer and
then thus that you know an sets the
layout and links them together but
that's actually already happened why
because we've created a vertex array and
obviously the create function for vertex
array as you can see has bound it right
it's done oh actually no it hasn't
because we haven't called bind that's
interesting so that might actually save
us anyway um it does for vet his buffer
obviously if we look at this all right
because we have to upload the data
that's why so unless we unbind this it's
going to kind of bind itself to the
vertex array so that's kind of the the
situation that we're kind of
do we end up with which is a little bit
annoying because of over in jail but
anyway I'm going to not worry about any
of that because I don't think that it's
going to actually stop anything from
working I think that we might just be
somewhat confused and end up kind of
debugging the state of our application a
bit more than we would otherwise if the
API was better
it also means people might misuse this
it's hard for me to try and anticipate
all people misusing this so I'll kind of
leave it as is and see what happens and
based on the usage of this kind of API
inside our engine in the future we may
start unbinding things or dealing with
some kind of different way of doing
things anyway
surveillance array we create the Vettes
array doesn't matter that we're doing it
here by the way can be anywhere we add
the vertex buffer to the vertex array
after has been created and after we've
set a layer house okay
that's important and we're kind of
garrard let's go I think that's
important that we do this after the
layout has been set because if we do it
before it's not gonna do anything right
because you can see that here it
actually does this code which depends on
the layout so that's important if it has
no layout or Lauer's empty where you
could have set over here and say that
like there's nothing there's no elements
in the layout in fact that's probably
something that I actually do want to do
so we'll say I just said cor assert and
we'll say basically that the vertex
buffer layout get elements size right so
basically the size of the elements has
to not be zero right otherwise you could
say that the vertex buffer has nailed
how's my layout so we'll say about its
buffer has no layout okay and I'll put
that as the very first thing in the
function all right that's just a little
god in case then we can test that out in
a minute
in case you accidentally do that because
in that case this won't work even though
even though the API might seem like it
does okay now again what you could do to
make that work by the way is you could
enter the vertex buffer you could add a
reference to the vertex array the vertex
level belongs to so what I mean by that
is when you
vertex buffer it just sets its parent
essentially inside the vertex buffer
itself so this function just goes ahead
and says you know you wouldn't pass it
by constantly more I guess the function
the the this function goes ahead and
just says vertex buffer dot vertex array
or that I've had a parent order equals
of this and that way it's got that
connection and then when you update the
vertex buffers layout right it can
update the vertex array that is part of
or vertex array is that it's part of if
it's multiple so that's food for thought
but not something that I really want to
do and then finally we create our index
buffer and I also want to add that into
into here okay cool so add index buffer
and index buffer and that's totally not
a thing for this both set okay cool
there we go so now the idea is we can
unbind everything we can create a whole
bunch of these right it's kind of hard
to demonstrate in this one example just
because it is so easy I guess alright it
is sort of simple in a sense that we're
just creating one of everything but if
we had multiple we could just go ahead
and keep creating all of our other ones
let's just say we're loading a bunch of
meshes we could you know create and load
all of our meshes here and then when we
bind it that's when it's actually going
to kick in and use all this all the
state that we've associated with it now
so over here obviously we're going to do
vertex array dot bind right and then
we're just going to render using draw
elements just like we have all this time
right using the count from the index
buffer I think that is pretty much it so
we should be able to just run this code
and overflow compiles and hopefully runs
as expected and now it doesn't even
compile okay so very sorry definition
yeah that's because we used to have this
unsigned int called vertex array we can
delete that now let's go ahead and try
again okay here's another error on it
okay this yep we need to include hazel
platform they're not inside hazel that's
just platform I think I was surprised by
that last time as well
great way to know your own codebase show
no f5 and what we should see is exactly
the same result as last time hopefully
yep cool everything looks like it works
we could go ahead and just create
another version I guess and see how that
works I guess I will go ahead and do
that just quickly so we'll try and
create something completely different I
guess to test this out
I said I would also test out the assert
so let's try and add the vertex buffer
before we actually set the layout see if
it lets us without complaining because
he doesn't it says that love has no
layout right asserts and then we're like
oh we must not have we must not have set
a layout yet for our vertex welcome okay
great so let's go ahead and create maybe
a square so I'll basically need all
three of these right now that's not
technically true now I need the count
right because I need to know the count
the index buffers count right that is
something we could add to vertex arrays
right write it like really like to the
vertex right because we don't have an
API to retrieve what it stores at the
moment I'm gonna go ahead and add that
there so we'll say a virtual STD vector
STD share the pointer vertex buffer all
right
there's gonna be a Const and cost
reference and get the vertex buffers
cons equals zero all right and we'll
have the same thing but not the vector
and that will be for our index buffer so
index buffer get index buffer right and
we'll copy this and we'll go into our
opengl vertex array and we'll just make
these gathers let me just move this out
of the way and this will just be a
little return betting buffers right so
we get the whole collection here and
this will return index for fun okay cool
so now our API is capable of that which
is important because we're going to use
it now so over here
instead of creating like all you know
three of these we can just say we want
the vertex array right I'll call this
something like square vertex array
because this is our um I'll just call it
square V a square Bettis right right
this is gonna be we're gonna make a
square instead of a triangle here so
what we'll do is we'll kind of go over
here we've got a shader maybe before the
shader I'll create this right so don't
reset and then vertex array create I'll
have to creating a vertex buffer so
we'll say STD shared pointer vertex
buffer square V beam equals s CD make
shared vertex buffer and then we'll have
to take in the vertices so we'll copy
and paste these vertices and what I want
to do here is a little bit different
than before because that's kind of the
point of testing this this is actually
not gonna have any vertex colors at all
now this is gonna be a little bit
controversial because the shader
actually expects vertex it needs that
color right you have to either use a
different shader or whatever because
it's otherwise it's just not gonna work
so what we might do is just quickly
create a new shader or we can just go
ahead and check to see I guess if that's
been set or not which might not be great
though we could add a uniform there's a
few things we could do but we'll just
see if it maybe rent as a black square
for us if we don't supply that vet tech
start up but it's a bit it's a bit dodgy
you shouldn't be doing things like that
so maybe I'll just quickly copy and
paste make a new shed I'll probably will
do that actually let's copy and paste
this share to quickly and a vertex
source you know - because I'm that
imaginative and also I just want to get
this going and this will just do that
and it will just have that that's the
only difference really so we've got rid
of V color right it's just got the
attribute position and then the color is
just gonna be set to the I guess this
but we could set a flat color if we
wanted to let's make our let's make it
like blue I guess okay so this just sets
it to blur and we'll get rid of that as
well okay cool and then this will be
ouch
second trader am shada - I hate this
naming as much as you do don't worry
we'll copy this and shared it - I can't
I just caught I'm sorry we're gonna call
it blue shade up because I can't just
call it that um blue shade a better
source I just remember that I have to
push this to get up so there's no way
that I'm doing curd with such bad naming
be more descriptive use longer variable
names if you have to trust me it's the
best way to go okay so now we have two
different things here as well so this is
just gonna be as I said a square so
instead of doing all this we'll still
have this at 0.5 we'll just adjust these
vertices so that we're dealing with a
square there's gonna be three times four
and this will be negative on the X okay
that looks like a square to me good now
we're going to create that vertex buffer
and just like we did with our we can't
actually make it this way by the way cuz
it isn't a constructor so we can we can
just we can either just leave it like
that and then reset it or we can
probably do make shared maybe with
vertex buffer create and then we'll have
to pop what to put in the vertices which
are our square vertices and in the size
of them so size of square bases okay and
that should be okay great so then we
need to say we need to create a layout
and set it and add it to the vertex
buffer as pettalia the word eyesore ages
like here so we'll say square V V layout
all right I mean you could just put this
right in here by the way if you really
wanted to you could just write code like
this right and that would work why we
might just do that just for fun so that
you guys can see two different ways of
doing it but yeah we can just set the
layout to be that which is also kind of
makes it look really nice cool so
there's our layout and then we're adding
it to the square V a right
and what we're doing is Square baby okay
cool so now we basically transfer
ownership into this vertex buffer
because it's a shared pointer mm-hmm and
and this scope will actually expire but
this variable rather in the scope will
obviously end when the square bands but
it still lives on inside our vertex
buffer indices so copy this put it here
we'll call this square indices will make
six of them 0 1 2 2 3 0 index buffers
gonna be we're just gonna make a new one
right so this is going to be the same as
this except IB and index buffer we can
just go ahead and do make shared I guess
you can also do reset as I said but that
requires 2 lines of code so I guess
we'll just do this and we're doing
that'll create there's gonna be our
square indices of course that looks
pretty good
we might have I need another parenthesis
this needs to be an index alpha ok cool
and then we just set the index ball
fight into our vertex array obviously
being the square VA ok that's it
if we scroll down here we can see how
this works so we'll still bind our
shader we can actually draw two at once
might be weird maybe we'll draw the
triangle on top of the square
so I'll might draw the square first so
we'll say square V a bind right we'll
bind our square shader as well or our
blue shadow combined right and then
we'll do draw elements we'll draw
triangles this will be square V a index
buffer and get index buffer get count
okay then we bind the shadow vertex
array and then we just you know do the
now triangle so let's just see what
happens here hopefully everything's
gonna work I did kind of rush through
this okay we go to same time Sara I
guess yep
I don't know why but my parentheses are
just leaving me
[Applause]
that is above a kind of essentially an
abstract class yeah okay I've kind of
thought that would happen
to be completely honest it's because
this is still a constructor so I guess
we can either set it directly which
should actually work if we just do that
although although I think maybe not yeah
this becomes a little bit we will
eventually return a I would have full
measure to make sure would have worked
but I don't want to deal with it right
now so just what does do it this way um
eventually we will return she had
pointers as their returning role
pointers so it'll be fine
but yeah what's to reset for now okay
cool f5 all right cool so we have it
looks like it's still drunk drawing
three vertices but it does look like
it's drawing two things and with
different shaders which is nice now why
is it drawing three vertices this
definitely looks like it should have
more than three like as in we're setting
is quite indices to like that's six
right because there's six in here and
then over here we I thought we were
getting the count out of this so I'm
suspicious now about our index buffer so
if we look at buffer right we have get
count from GL index buffer jail buffer
get counters returns em count and I
guess we're setting that right why
wouldn't we be em count is being set to
count that is quite strange I wonder why
we're only drawing that many a quick way
to check is just to make sure we
actually draw six by just calling six
directly and I might have to disable the
other stuff because this might not be
working yep okay cool so it's probably
our layout that's actually wrong
unfortunately because I was hoping that
that would just be a piece of cake but
that being said I did rush through this
so who knows what kind of code I really
wrote and there's the problem so we have
an index buffer being set into our
square but ice ray that's actually the a
mean desktop
which is the anti self-aware just three
vertices so make sure that we set the
square IB right and then we can go down
and actually change this back to being
vertex was square ba get indexed buffer
dot get count okay f5 and now we should
see both the square in the background
and the triangle in the foreground and
as you can see that's what we get here
so the same size which is why you see it
like this
let's make it a little bit more
interesting and just make this maybe 75
instead of five just so that we kind of
have it as a background and we have the
triangle rendering in front and a little
bit smaller there we go okay pretty cool
we have both of these things now
rendering lets one more thing that i
want to do before we finish today is
just clean up the code a bit you'll
notice that we don't actually need to
have vertex buffer or index buffer here
anymore so I'm just going to delete both
of these right so we kind of just have
this and that that's just gonna mean
that we're gonna have to do a similar
thing to what we do here where we kind
of created this stuff first so we'll do
we'll just call this vertex buffer so
I'll just be kind of our plain example I
guess and so we'll just replace this and
then this will do the same thing for
here which will just be index buffer
we'll call it
index buffer will do in this buffer
reset as usual and said buffer okay
there we go
f5 hopefully this all works and we
actually have some errors here let's see
and oh yeah we use it here so this will
obviously now just becomes an vertex for
a get index profile you get count um and
I think that should be it
so let's just see what we get here you
can see it's working which is great
last thing I'll do to clean this up as
well is we need to actually delete a
vertex array so I didn't add a
destructor because I just had this thing
here so we will
just copy this go below the constructor
make this a function and just hold GL
delete vertex arrays okay and this will
be one and M vertex and render ID and
render ID okay cool
just make sure that everything still
works and I think that's pretty much it
so hopefully this kind of helps you guys
understand how that x-rays work and how
we're gonna use them and now we kind of
have almost almost enough code where we
can actually not you know write OpenGL
code to make any of this stuff happen
and we can actually move this into
sandbox into the sandbox app instead of
actually having it inside application
the last piece of the puzzle is
literally this draw elements and we're
going to talk about that in the next
episode okay so I hope you guys enjoyed
this episode if you did even hit the
like button you can also help support
this series by going over to patreon
icon 4/2 Cherno huge thank you as always
to all the patrons that make this series
possible if you support the series
you'll get rewarded by just you get some
rewards such as getting access to the
source code of my kind of private
development repository of hazel where
we've got like the AA rendering and just
like a full 3d scene and a lot of really
cool stuff um that's kind of in
development there next time as I said I
want to talk about the renderer and how
that plays a role and where that Childre
elements is going because that's how I
actually like draw command as our actual
drawer cool and yeah we're kind of move
on with this and probably start kind of
building putting together like an actual
3d scene I'll see you guys then
good bye
[Music]